how did you become sad saboteur is a
version of Barry from the future he
remembers everything that Barry does if
you use this I list is going to die
tonight know what you are your time
remedy temporal duplicate created when
you run back in time to meet yourself
you brought a remnant to life last year
to consume your duplicate died saving
the multiverse and you continued your
happy little life and there would have
stayed that way but then you decided to
play God
you created flashed and changed
everything go into the future but future
self told me that he created time
remnants to stop you that you
slaughtered them all over one me I lived
but a funny thing happened when I did
hey youtubers is Charlie so I got a lot
of requests to explain sabotage full
timeline and how he can work because
he's a future version of Barry but how
did the first version of Barry becomes
avatar because it's this big mobius
strip so it's really confusing so
there's a new brand of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so this is how sabotage time line
works it's engineered such that Barry
will always become a version of sabotage
or create a version of sabotage
so this avatar will always continue to
exist in the future
just for the sake of argument we'll call
this version of sabotage that just
revealed himself to Barry the second
version of sabotage because the way he
explains it is that in the future iris
dies and Barry trying to stops avatar
this future version of Barry that we met
in 2024 creates time remnants to stop
him sabotage kills them all except for
one lets him to live so that he can
eventually become sabotage after
saboteur lets him live they go back to
their lives future Barry goes back to
the team but now there are two Barry's
because one of the time remnants is
still alive time remnant Barry explains
that the team shunned him it drove him
crazy
he couldn't handle the pain and got the
bright idea that God doesn't feel pain
so he would become sabotage now that's
when he starts going back in time to
find the philosopher's stone uses that
to become savat are then he starts
jumping up and down the timeline
collecting acolytes creating the myth of
sabotage so that people like Jay Garrick
in episode 9 can tell Barry the tale of
sabotage not a lot is known about him
you're powerful enough now so he's
coming to challenge you but he doesn't
stop there we actually have confirmation
now that future Barry from legends of
tomorrow that left that message was
talking about sabotage when the legends
found that message in the Waverider from
old you saying don't trust Barry Allen
who was talking about Savitt our very
own oh it's all coming together in the
worst way because future Barry had found
out that he was jumping around in the
timeline wearing his face so he was
telling them do not trust me obviously
they left a lot of important information
off of that message because you think
the good future version of Bear
if he was going to warn his past selves
and all of his friends about sabotage he
would say sabotage wearing my face but I
think that's just a little bit of TV
logic they didn't want to reveal the
secret that quickly what's happening in
present day is the time is moving at the
normal pace we get new episodes week to
week we learn a little bit more about
sabotage then you get moments in episode
9 where saboteur gives them the prophecy
of what's going to happen and says you
bury you trap me in this Speed Force
prison so now you're like okay how can
all this future sabotage stuff be
happening but all this stuff is still
happening in present day so the key to
sabotage is that you have all of these
time-travel adventures that he's
happening in the background and then you
have the adventures in present-day that
are moving in real time so that's how
one day saboteur can go back in time
create the myth of sabotage then that
next day jump back to the future in save
fight the future version of Barry Allen
that eventually defeats him and traps
him in the speedforce prison
so the actual Barry that defeated Sava
tar wasn't from this legends of tomorrow
message that was from like way far in
the future Salvatore was defeated by
this version of Barry Allen if that
wasn't clear he just neglected to tell
Barry about the time remnant twist so
sometime between when he created Sava
tar and defeated him Sava tar traveled
to the very very far future in messed
with future Barry Allen stuff so that's
where that very far future message comes
from so the timeline is a complete mess
and it's all engineered such that Barry
Allen will always end up creating a
version of sabotage because surprisingly
it's not that hard to stops avatar the
reason why it seems so dangerous is
because sabotage so fast and as Barry
changes things Sava Tarr learns them
because he's a future version of Barry
so for every new plan Barry comes up
with saboteur learns about it instantly
so it just creates a lot of problems in
reality the easiest way to get rid of
sabotage is just to remove Barry Allen
from the equation and it is a measure of
last resort you have all these powers
back there's a number of ways the team
could takes avatar down and just not
tell Barry about any of it so thats
avatar wouldn't learn and you said to
hope this avatar was not quick enough to
stop them that is why sabot R looks like
he's trying to break Wally's back in the
promo for the next episode
so that Wally is off the tape
because you do need to buy to speed
certify to speedster in Cisco hasn't
learned the ability that gypsy has to
cut speedsters off from the Speed Force
that's what she's doing when she stops
Wally dead in his tracks you could do
that to saboteur and it would totally
work so I think we're going to see gypsy
again soon maybe she'll help Cisco with
that but that's just another way that
you could stops avatar it's not as bad
as it seems
it's just that Barry is such a big part
of the process thats avatar keeps
learning about all their plans I know
there's still a lot of questions about
who the technical first version of
savage heart was because the time
remnant here says thats avatar let him
live so that he could become sabotage so
where did that version of sabotage come
from the simplest answer is that a
future version of Barry created a time
remnant at some point for some reason
that time remnant was ostracized just
like this version that we're talking to
in that start of the cycle of sabotage
so another big lesson of the season is
don't play God don't do things like
flashpoint you have the power of a god
just because you can change time doesn't
mean that you should but the other side
lesson is don't create time remnants now
you know why zoom kept killing his time
remnant he probably figured out the same
thing that Barry's figuring out right
now one of them might get the idea to go
bad and try and get rid of you so that
he's the true version of Barry Allen
isn't it funny how much Barry has
learned that helped him from fighting
the villain he learned all about time
travel from eobard thawne in season one
then he learned all about time remnants
in season two from zoom then learned
about flashpoint from you Bart Thawne
again in season three so I know there's
still a lot of questions about why the
black flash hasn't completely destroyed
this version of the time remnant if
eobard thawne time remnant was being
chased down by the black flash then why
is it that the Speed Force is giving a
pass to this crazy version of sabotage
that is doing way worse things so
that'll be another video sometime next
week but leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below if
there's anything you guys want me to
explain I know there's a bunch of season
4 stuff happening with the Deveaux
villain so because we're nearing the
season finale start thinking about the
weekly flash videos that you guys want
me to do during the break it's not going
to take that long before we get details
about season 4 but I'll kind of explain
what the time line is going to be for
the summer what the schedule is going to
look like I'll still be doing a couple
flash bonus videos a week so you guys
can decide what those videos are about
my next video is going to be Wonder
Woman I have some new footage and there
is a ton of good news a bunch of people
got to see the movie and it is probably
the best news that you ever wanted to
hear about the future of the DC EU it's
going to be awesome so I'll post that in
a little while but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner bradley
fourtner please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details on announce the
next winner when I post that Wonder
Woman video while you wait for that you
can click here to learn about a brand
new DC TV show that's going to start
next year and you can click here to
learn all about the thor ragnarok
guardians of the galaxy crossover thank
you so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight